[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
et joue présente toutes ses participants
jean charles naveau ni bonjour toujours
éditeurs toujours éditeurs plan toujours
être avec mon livre alors qu'à des bons
jours toujours un chat vocal et on va
parler d'ailleurs un avocat qui fait
parler de lui tout allait vous donnerez
votre sentiment
confrères sur et admiratrices à spatiaux
et admirative peut-être à servian bezina
bonjour bonjour millions de droits des
gens constituent la science po et à
l'université d'oran et mustapha larfaoui
bonjour toujours là pharmaciens correct
trappe
toujours président d'honneur du football
club de trappes correct correct les
haies et créateur d'une école qui
s'appelle l'école de commerce de trappes
c'est dans le cadre de l'association
fermat citoyen est aussi président de
pharmacie voilà donc faire un citoyen
beaucoup d'affaires beaucoup d'action
sur la ville de trappes en particulier
et on a
décidé de créer donc cette école de
commerce de trappes qui s'adresse à des
étudiants de 18 à 25 ans après avoir
créé l'académie dont on a beaucoup parlé
ici parce que laquelle est mis sous à
l'académie qui s'adresse donc à des
enfants de cm2 tous les enfants etc pour
du renfort en maths française voilà donc
le principe c'est d'aller les chercher à
l'école en bus leur payer le goûter et
puis donc de faire donc des maths et du
français
et d'enchaîner ensuite sur le foot
puisque c'est il s'agit d'une classe de
football donc du club de foot de tram 15
alors là c'est un peu différent
donc l'idée c'est de se dire moi
j'aimerais bien pouvoir faire tous les
âges l'enseignement étant
particulièrement important à mes yeux et
donc on est qu'associatif donc on s'est
demandé où est ce qu'on pouvait agir de
nouveau donc du coup on a fait les
scènes les cm2 et le post bac donc 18 25
ans voilà c'est donc là c'est pour les
18 25 ans et en même temps c'est aussi
pour dire parce que je suis très
identifiée sur le foot
et c'est aussi pour dire que bien peu
fou que le foot dans la main a
clairement et aussi le commerce
il ya aussi un engagement parce que vous
avez les deux casquettes dans vaduz
avait 2 de commerces
voilà des faits parce que mes mais à qui
s'adressent alors alors comme je vous
l'aï dit ça s'adresse à des jeunes de 18
ans blessé des gens question n'est pas
l'onuci ont débaptisé qui ont donc le
bac ou le niveau bac
et ça s'adresse donc à des jeunes qui ne
vont pas pouvoir accéder à d'une part à
des écoles plus prestigieuses d'école de
commerce
ils ne sont pas la présidentielle qui
viennent là mais où après vos après
parce qu'ils auront des choses à
apprendre
donc c'est ça non non on prend des
malades et des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément des diplômes voilà ou qui ont
juste le bac
voilà le bac niveau bac et plus il ya
déjà 2 bac + 3 maintenant en fait l'idée
c'est d'aller directement
cherchez les facteurs clés de succès qui
permettent de rentrer dans l'entreprise
vous dit est mieux adaptée c'est un peu
l'idée de transmettre les codes de
l'entreprise comme il peut y avoir les
codes dans différents dans différents
dans différentes matières différents
milieux
il ya des codes chez les journalistes il
ya des codes dans les banlieues il ya
des codes un peu partout dans ces
groupes constitués et dans l'entreprise
l'entreprise a également ses voiles à
ses façons d'être ses façons de se
comporter et puis voilà il ya des
moments où il ya des attitudes qui fait
que l'entreprise est plus adapté ou plus
proche d'un enseignement concret là
concrètement ce sont des profs qui
viennent que de l'entreprise donc ya pas
de cours magistraux ce sont des gens qui
appartiennent à la société civile d'une
panne en même temps à l'entreprise
surtout et qui viennent donner leur
expérience le cv pour moi compte
beaucoup
comment on en est arrivé là depuis le
plus jeune âge parce qu'ils sont
concernés aussi par un jeune âge ils le
sont encore et c'est le parcours qui
m'intéresse
ensuite expliqué différents métiers
parce que chaque professeur sera et
choisis dans un secteur d'activité
différents donc on aura différents
secteurs d'activité ils viendront parler
de leur métier de leur profession et en
même temps de ce qu'ils font au
quotidien donc c'est vraiment très très
pratique
c'est vraiment basé sur l'expérience ce
que l'aller en fin d'année pour finir
patrice il ya une notion de tutorat
également c'est à dire que ceux qui vont
venir à l'école on va les accompagner
également dans les recherches de stages
d'emplois
et puis l'idée c'est un peu le slow
d'haïti dire que plutôt que les faire
rencontrer des chefs d'entreprise de
façon extrêmement rapide
là pour le coup on va prendre le temps
avec cette classe qui s'adresse à une
vingtaine de jeunes pas plus ça sert à
rien une vingtaine par l'om sur ouais
ouais c'est ça et elle est la durée des
études c'est quoi alors on a commencé
parce qu'il fallait lancer cette école
j'ai jugé bon principe et pour habitude
de commencer toujours très doucement et
et là on a voulu commencer en janvier
pour un petit peu amorcé cette première
classe donc ça va se terminer fin juin
et puis ça reprendra l'an prochain on
dès octobre pour une saison complète
cette fois ci mais ça veut dire que la
scolarité c'est quoi c'est un an ces six
mois s'est plusieurs années ce sera ce
sera un an puisque accor et renault
commencerait donc cette fois ci à
l'information jusqu'en juin ça commence
par une première classe qui serait
vraiment basé que sur l'expérience des
intervenants quand une fois parler des
métiers parler de la profession et leur
expérience et puis là dessus viendront
viendront s'ajouter tous les cours
importants donc de l'entreprise on aura
besoin probablement de connaître le
droit constitutionnel que c'est
important d'élargir le spectre le
spectre des connaissances et le commerce
en particulier mais voilà on commerce de
tous on vend tout et tout se vend et
donc ce que le droit social
ce qui sera important c'est bah c'est de
connaître encore une fois vendredi tous
les cordes tous les corps de métiers et
voilà donc le droit bien évidemment
important dans l'environnement il peut
lire ici est important donc y aura des
cours de gestion évidemment des finances
de communication marketing
moi je viendrai tout simplement parler
de mon expérience d'accord mais pas de
cours non non non c'est je laisse ça aux
pros d'accord d'accord on peut se
renseigner
on peut sur cette école oui donc l'appel
l'école le global de tram le lien donc
ferme un citoyen pharmacie d'ordures de
toutes attachées pharma citoyens @
orange.fr merci de me donner ce temps
les patries pharma citoyenne on a juste
une page facebook fond on communique à
minima c'est vrai que c'est juste pour
donner des informations
mais on n'a pas cette prétention à
vouloir communiquer au delà on est
vraiment très centrée sur les actions
sur sur trappe
j'insiste pour le dire comme ça j'ai pas
la prétention en forêt et cherche depuis
large
c'est vraiment sur trappe donc et ça
s'adresse ça commence maintenant à ça
sur les dix longueurs de trappes on peut
postuler
bien sûr c'est pas exclusivement pour
les graphistes sauf que sauf qu'il ya 20
places et que là ça se remplit très vite
et 7 millions ça ne peut pas être
exclusif par définition mais c'est vrai
que c'est quand même orienté sur la
population sur le public de trappes
c'est un peu pour ça que je les fais je
pense que c'est à d'autres classes qui
disent par ailleurs d'autres façons de
procéder par ailleurs auquel par
définition ils n'y ont pas accès c'est
là ça l'idée les scolarités payante ou
non absolument pas gratuit non mais donc
il ya une sélection des conditions du
prêt c'est vrai
entre 18 et 25 ans niveau bac et puis
beaucoup de foot de trappes parti de
faire ses courses j'attrape dans les
pharmacies donc voila mon renconter
candidats et est ce qu'on cherche c'est
vraiment voilà c'est vraiment
l'engagement du jeune la motivation et
voilà c'est franchement c'est tout parce
que j'ai jamais très trop regardant sur
dans ma vie professionnelle sur les cv
techniquement mais j'ai besoin d'aller
rechercher les gens au delà même si en
janvier on sait plus à gauche et quand
même décès et c'est pas simple et non
pas qu'il ya un projet c'est vraiment
l'envi le projet c'est moi ils ont des
tous des projets personnels mais voilà
c'est surtout pour démythifier parce que
attrape à traces pour bien connaître
cette jeunesse pour l'avoir connu et
même pour être avec elle très très
régulièrement club de foot en
particulier mais c'est vrai qu'on
mythifie beaucoup de choses on se fait
une image de l'entreprise effet une
image de de ces écoles et à peut-être un
peu complexe ouais c'est ça va et donc
on n'ose pas là il faut oser sachant que
si on pouvait les emmener par ce
tremplin à d'autres écoles de commerce
en tous les cas à sentir qu'on peut
continuer ses études
bien après ou le bac ou avoir eu des
diplômes
c'était en même temps c'est un peu
chaque séjour parole on fait des choses
faire dépenser
moi j'ai repris mes études à 25 ans
voilà donc on peut les reprendre même
tard le mieux c'est pas les abandonner
essayez de comprendre pourquoi justement
eu cet abandon ou ses échecs et comme on
peut rebondir
il ya des écoles par exemple celle de la
deuxième jambe vrai qu'ils sont si on
est un peu sur le même créneau mais sur
d'autres secteurs d'activité c'est un
peu cette idée alors y est quelqu'un que
vous pour faire venir maintenant que me
peut-être pour raconter ses dires et
henry s'il voulait un peu de temps et il
a peut-être des choses à raconter sur le
management des comment comment réussit
on ne réussit pas avec un groupe mais ce
qu'il faut pas être né secours n'est pas
un peu jeune pour avoir un groupe en
difficulté enfin c'est vrai que c'était
il vient d'être licenciées rappelle de
du club de monaco où il était venu
arrivé il ya trois mois il va être
remplacé par leonardo jardim qu'il avait
succédé qui revient de resigner
c'est quand même donc c'est vrai au
niveau management c'est intéressant
c'est curieux parce que d'abord seul
tout le monde va dire qu'effectivement
il suffit pas de bien jouer pour être
etc
je crois que et là c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça et que après c'est une
île a pas non plus une équipe qui est
absolument extraordinaire alors vous
allez me dire ils ont recruté les très
bons joueurs mais mais une équipe de
foot face à face est très bien c'est pas
juste une accumulation de très bons
joueurs sinon ça c'est
raison l'équipe de france à 50 soit aimé
jacquet ou où deschamps on vient montrer
que c'est une équipe c'est pas forcément
les meilleurs joueurs c'est qu'ils sont
intéressantes c'est que est ce que
justement ces très grands joueurs comme
de communes a été comme comme les
deschamps comme tu es blanc etc
ils sont et ils sont aptes à entraîner
des exécutions aux difficultés ou est-ce
qu'ils sont plutôt entraîner d'autres
très grands joueurs pour ce qu'ils sont
meilleurs quand ils ont de très bons
joueurs avec eux et la deuxième chose
c'est que c'était son premier club comme
entraîneur
et quand vous rentrez tôt dans le dur il
faut peut-être avoir un peu d'expérience
mais vous avez raison moi je ne suis par
exemple persuadé que zidane à la place
de thierry henry mais le real de madrid
où aller il peut jouer au real c'est
vous êtes deux trucs différents il ya
des il ya des il ya des vieux aux
traders français là qu'ils ont aussi
servi du honduras un voile et au revoir
il y aller tous ensemble des terrains
comme le dit jean charles c'est vrai que
c'est une entreprise on en a on y
revient et cette fois ci j'ai mis des
guillemets mais c'est vrai que ça ne
fonctionne pas uniquement parce qu'on va
voir les meilleurs joueurs il ya
d'autres équipes qui l'ont trouvée par
contre il ya d'autres équipes qui ont
prouvé de l' inverse puisque quand on
quand on agrège les meilleurs au psg par
exemple ça fait quand même quelques
performances en même temps thierry mais
s'il est un jeu d'équipé d'ailleurs
c'est tout problème
moi la seule question que je me pose
c'est c'est ce qu'il a été tout
simplement accepter par ses joueurs ça
que c'est même plus une qualité deux
joueurs étaient honorés ce qu'il a été
acceptée réellement ou est ce qui a paru
un front un front anti ans et je sais
pas et pour le coup ce qui me laisse à
penser qu'on n'est pas loin de sept
jours peut se poser la question si l'on
a rappelé
son prédécesseur donc est ce qu'il n'ya
pas eu quelque chose de frontale skis a
pas eu quelque chose qui fait que ça n'a
pas fonctionné qui tend en tout cas ce
que ça parle mais on sait aujourd'hui
qu'il est écarté mais pas renvoyé il a
créé son salaire ou encore deux millions
et demi ça c'est ouais c'est à dire que
c'est un plat sert problèmes d'argent
sous forme parce que oui c'est quand
même assez sympathique mais de toute
façon sur banshee
si le talent beaucoup de gens qu'ils ont
effectivement leur salaire si le
licencie sont obligés de lui payer au
moins sont contraignants pour lui c'est
pas une question d'argent parce qu'il
n'a pas besoin d'argent je crois
beaucoup
c'est pas pour ça que le faible et et
puis oui c'est pas des pannes on va se
dire ils passent un temps financièrement
corps c'est toi qui le fait c'est comme
carlos il a jamais rien
carlos car2go d'affilée pas la
motivation principale
cet appétit pour l'argent on peut
effectivement vouloir en stocker de plus
en plus mais je pense pas que ça soit la
motivation première en tous les cas pour
je parle pour tirer en rien altéré
quel est le statut de monaco dont c'est
une monarchie constitutionnelle mais je
suis très compétente en matière
footballistique même si j'admire cette
photo thierry henry qui a les rebelles
voilà deux d'y croire là la petite le
parallèle est la transition qu'on peut
faire avec ce qu'on va dire ensuite de
l'état de la france et c'est cette
question du management d'un groupe qui
pour moi est la même chose quand on
quand on prend le président la
république ou celui qui va diriger
l'ensemble des français c'est est ce
qu'il faut s'en référer au groupe et est
ce que finalement c'est la qualité du
groupe qui compte ou est ce que c'est la
qualité du leader qui va influencer le
groupe et le rendre de meilleure qualité
je crois que c'est une plaie non savoir
qu'elle figure on empruntait ce qu'il
fait chaud par exemple est également la
qualité du groupe est plus importante
que la qualité des individualités
à noter amorce jacquet bon peut-être
parler d'un avocat qui fait beaucoup
parler de lui c'est maître
dupond-moretti qui monte sur scène est
ce que c'est dans le milieu des avocats
cci là de jouer sur sept sont une pièce
alors dans laquelle il raconte ce qui
est en rapport avec sa progression
puisqu'il raconte sa profession il va
raconter des affaires qu'il a plaidé
est ce que c'est on en parle c'est dans
le 2004 sa baisse contre ça normal
est-ce que non pas du tout du tout
est-ce que vous ne payez pas le risque
après quand vous plaidez alors lui c'est
un avocat de deux pénalités analystes de
vos cabas 6 quai les gens se disent les
jurés je sais pas oui il joue la comédie
coiffeuse de théâtre aussi de toute
façon dans mon cas ce que j'ai au moins
dans le procès criminel c'est à dire
qu'on a vraiment besoin d'un décorum de
21 des deux corps de théâtralité d'une
oralité qui est quand même qui fait
partie aussi notre tradition historique
française donc
le ap à mon avis le risque qu'ils
courent c'est celui de la pipolisation
un petit peu comme on a mal entendu le
stand le revendique
c'est vrai que j'aime bien être connu
j'aime bien être
alors ça se décrédibilise aux yeux de
certains mais au contraire ça lui gagne
de la popularité aux yeux d'autres aussi
donc ça si j'allais jouer au golf
personne ne dira rien moi ça m'amuse
plus dans les stades de ces offres et
donc je sais jaloux de libérer les gens
c'est que toutes et toutes les places
sont et c'est bien joué à guichet fermé
il rajouté
alors qu'il fait la une pourquoi on en
parle parce qu'il fait line de l'ops en
condamnant un siècle
hyper moralisateur ce qu'on appelle la
houle a bien pensants sur le
politiquement correct et le riz il
analyse un certain nombre de thèmes non
la société de la transparence dont le
fait que ya un thème qui me semblait
intéressant qui est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui pour être entendu on ne
peut pas voir de positions modérées
il faut aller aux ailes et du coup on
est très divisé c'est à dire qu'ils
mangent de la viande contre les spéciste
les chasseurs entraînement chasseurs
débuts contre les non fumeurs c'est vrai
que chacun à son camp comme ça chacun à
cette communauté son communautarisme et
je trouve ça c'est l'idée qui est assez
intéressante de dray mais je ne sais pas
ce que vous en faites pas on résumer ma
pensée
oui sinon je voulais surtout dire que
c'est d'autant plus accentuée enfin ces
communautés où ce communautarisme
d'autant plus accentuée par les fameux
réseaux sociaux qui socialisent
absolument pas bien au contraire mais
qui font qu'on va rechercher que des
gens qui pensent comme soit donc on va
sur la communauté
x y z et on ne recherche pas par
définition quelque chose qui peut
élargir son j'ai presque envie de dire
son face à sa façon de penser vous
cherchez à comprendre un peu comment
fonctionnent les autres mais au
contraire comment moi je fonctionne en
m'assurant en étant rassurés en allant
chercher ce que pensent les autres mais
on a été hors charges que ceux qui
pensent comme toi je pense est clair ce
que je me disais mais c'est plus ça qui
m'interpelle que le côté moralisateur et
en même temps il ya aussi cette ce désir
de communautarisme c'est aussi une
manière de se faire entendre
l'idée étant plus on est nombreux plus
on se fait entendre
l'union fait la force et donc nous on se
communautariser on se regroupe
mais le problème c'est que c'est
uniquement sur un sujet ça on va voir la
communauté des s'est passé pas tant pour
se faire entendre que pour se faire
accepter en tout cas pas se faire
rejeter parce que je vois par exemple
aux états unis il ya des gens de chez
google qu'ont porté plainte crois que
c'est google ou ou facebook contre le
leur entreprise dans dix ans on n'était
pas démocrate
on a osé dire qu'on était plutôt
républicain et on a été cassée très
nette progression parce qu'on était
éjecté du groupe bien pensants il se
trouve que dans une société il fallait
deux démocrates si on avait le malheur
de dire on est républicain
on était passé mais on en était déclassé
et c'est pareil en france dans beaucoup
de lieux surtout dans beaucoup de médias
il ya une sorte de bien pensants ce que
je rejoins tout à fait dupond moretti
si on n'est pas dans le cadre de tout ce
qu' une certaine presse une certaine
intelligentsia pape évoque est bien là
tout de suite on est considéré comme
soit un gros fachos un abruti les
violences et les ovationner la pression
ticket une libéralisation de la parole
nir des réalisations d'idées que
autrefois variés quelques années les
gens n'osaient pas soutenir même d'une
parole raciste un peu même on l'a
entendu vous allez demander si les
jaunes les allées vous allume cité
zemmour que tout le monde n'était alors
voilà par le libérer parce qu'il ya les
et la majorité des gens semble détester
zemmour la majorité des gens qui ont la
parole y achète sur les médias selon le
public aime bien et voilà donc nos mines
c'est vrai qu'il ya une paire
moralisation peut-être mais en même
temps de réalisation quand même failli
elle des sources qu'on n'osait pas dire
il ya quelques années qu'on dit
volontiers aujourd'hui c'est une
transparence pour chercher tout le monde
faire qu'en gros on veut savoir ce que
tu penses avant les gens passaient sur
les plateaux et on parlait de la langue
de bois donc on essaye d'en redescendre
au port ou dans quelque chose de plus
générale pour essayer d'avoir un maximum
de gens qui adhèrent votre propos est
aujourd'hui on a on est un peu plus
poussés vers la transparence cette idée
sur laquelle on veut savoir ce que vous
pensez donc ça se libéralise d'une part
il ya des il ya de plus en plus de
plateaux télé qui le permettent ce et
c'est beaucoup plus facile et en même
temps il ya quelque chose de sain je
trouve c'est qu'on veut savoir ce que tu
penses de savoir ce que vous pensez
c'est pas forcément très intéressant à
bâle c'est sa grand mère pour moi c'est
vraiment parler des valeurs
sa voix est ce que c'est très important
de savoir ce que pensent les gens est ce
que c'est très important des auditions
d'opinion mais comment parler c'est un
poney et on veut et on veut le dire
différemment de ce qui est dit sur les
plateaux donc c'est moi c'est à ça que
je pense je ne dis pas que c'est jeudi
que c'est simple parce qu'avant de il
faut que ce soit voilà maintenant est ce
que c'est bon parce que c'est bon j'en
sais rien est-ce que c'est forcément de
la transparence parce que c'est du buzz
le niveau haut niveau au niveau
journalistique de l'outil afin de siéger
parce que vous parliez vous parlez des
situations et ses carreaux s'est passé
s'est passé passé
enfin c'est pas sur votre toit il poste
demande une transparence et qu' il faut
qu'on sache tout de tout le monde des
gens qu'on élit il savoir combien de
juger comment sûrement comment
commandant de quel côté du 10
il se met le soir c'est ça la
transparence et si on veut savoir un
moment très politiquement correct par
exemple et gilet jaune personne j'ai
encore jamais vu sur un plateau
quelqu'un dire vraiment que les gilet
jaune c'est absolument il recevable
majorité de ce qu'ils lisent tout le
monde est déjà en train dire oui oui
c'est intéressant il faut prendre ça en
compte et que c'était une sorte et
bernard henri lévy qui dit très
justement dit il y en a marre de cette
génuflexion permanente devant les gilet
jaune mais c'est le seul qui ose le dire
c'est vrai qu'on en est ridicule tout le
monde est là ah oui il faut écouter
cette parole n'ont pas forcément mais
mais mais toujours d'élan ecoutons-la
écoutons là bas non bat yam et interdit
les jaunes on en reparlera peut-être
tout à l'heure
macron était au milieu des gilet jaune
n'ayez il y en a qui a dit il faut
dissolvez dit souvent on a parlé de des
réseaux sociaux tout à l'heure et moi je
crois que tout ce qu'on vit à l'heure
actuelle de la transparence et de la de
la radicalisation des discours est une
conséquence de ces réseaux sociaux parce
que je prends twitter on ne peut écrire
que des punchlines justement des tout
petits états et donc du coup le discours
le temps changent
on a des réseaux d'information continue
donc tout doit aller très vite et
directement à une information
essentielle clair arrêtez et trancher
donc moi je crois que c'est vraiment la
démocratie de ces réseaux là qu'on est
en train de vivre une démocratie de
l'immédiateté justement mon est obligé
d'aller au plus fort au plus vite
est ce que c'est ça démarre avec une
dératisation grand n'importe quoi n'est
pas forcément de développer alors est-ce
que ça parvient toujours au grand
n'importe quoi c'est forcément sûr à mon
avis étant donné que parfois c'est par
les réseaux sociaux qu'on a pu réussir à
créer des connexions chance au printemps
arabe aussi c'est bon comme ça un petit
peu que la jeunesse exprime et n'en est
certes un moment donc ça ne produit pas
que le pire néanmoins moi je crois en
eux essentiellement comme vous que
malheureusement quand on va directement
vers quelque chose de contestataires on
provoque du coup forcément les uns
contre les autres et moi ça évoque chez
moi ce rejet complet de la moralisation
et de la transparence parce que d'abord
je crois qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'on dit
parce que précisément les législateurs
qui ont pris je crois que c'est 13 loi
en moins de cinq ans en matière de
transparence et de moralisation de la
vie publique ou politique
eh bien ça prouve que de toute façon la
morale étant si on reprend les
philosophes quand yum
un sentiment naturel qui n'est chez
chacun comment arriver à faire des lois
universelles de moralisation et
transparence et comment arriver à en
faire un dogme absolu
donc moi je crois que le véritable
paradoxe qu'on rencontre c'est qu'on
veut qu'il y ait du bon et du mauvais on
va essayer de mettre des étiquettes mais
que néanmoins elles sont toujours
profondément personnelle donc ça revient
à ouvrir l'accès à tout le monde pour
dire quelle est sa morale et du coup
c'est là que ça peut ouvrir la porte au
grand n'importe quoi
mais sur le principe je crois que
libéraliser le discours s'est pas
forcément quelque chose de négatif mais
ça dépend après des opinions qu'on
écoute il ya justement dans une
université à de laure murat qui
enseignent des aux états unis qui défend
le politiquement correct en dix ans mais
après tout dire bonne fête au lieu de
dire joyeux noël comme avocat au sujet
d'après sur les catholiques mais eh ben
dis c'est au fossé respecter des gens
dont on connaît pas forcément la
religion ou s'ils ont une religion c'est
pas faux non plus les veux qu'on a pu
faire au niveau professionnel
on a souhaité professionnellement c'est
une adresse
maintenant c'est intéressant parce que
je peux le dire parce qu'il ya très peu
de temps dans les villes dans les
villages dans les villes des
éliminations c'était joyeux noël ont
souhaité joindre personne n'avait autant
n'étaient pas forcés d'être catholique
intégriste pour fêter noël à 17 espèces
de 2 août permanente que legend aulas
horreur vade retro satanas aulas on voit
une soutane on voit un truc mais on est
dans un truc ridicule
qu'est ce que c'est que ce soit je
pensais pas excessif que ça si on est
dans un mouvement de mondialisation et
puis qu'on accueille tout type de
personnes qui vont des convictions
différentes et de décongestionner qui
s'adapte en quoi je trouve qu'on est là
jeudi
ce qui fait légèrement adapté d'ailleurs
parce que le calendrier de nos jours
fériés et plus ou moins calqué sur les
fêtes chrétiennes et quelques débuts
pierre bergé qui voulait qu'ils
voulaient tous les baptisés attendait
plus noël on dit vacances de fin d'année
du ridicule
bientôt nos problèmes moi je comprends
mal problème moi pendant des années aux
fins de très tôt j'ai dit joyeux noël
parce que c'est comme ça que autour de
moi ça se passait les gens se souhaiter
un joyeux noël
je continue à dire joyeux noël dans
cette période là mais de la même façon
moubarak al-hamad à un moment donné si
je m'adresse à un public je sais que
c'est le ramadhan par un moment donné à
un moment donné il faut faire simple on
sait tous la période du ramadan que
c'est des gens font font le jeune on les
croise on leur dit tout ce bon ramadan
sans savoir d'ailleurs si le pratique
réellement mais on ne dit pas ce que
parce que facialement ça passe bien à la
fin du ramadan cmen caradec
voilà donc un moment donné où il faut
faire beaucoup plus s'adresse à moi
j'aime moi j'aime bien le joyeux noël
j'aime bien le dire dans cette période
parce qu'à pâques ça fait un peu ça fait
un peu décalé mais causé 10 ou bien beau
mais là j'ai presque envie de dire à la
bonne personne alors c'est là où ça
devient qu'on peut compliquer parce que
si je dis joyeux noël me dire ouais
maintenant moi je pratique pas un local
à madame c'est pas mon truc
on se faire simple et puis et puis je
trouve que c'est une manière aussi de ma
de reconnaître de les reconnaître tous
deux d'avoir une ouverture d'esprit donc
le joyeux noël ça doit faire partie d'un
d'un propos très simple et très très
décontracté au contraire maintenant des
spéciales dans pas de crispation de
votre caisse va suivre va justement
alors va regarder s'il ya un évêque
auxiliaire qui s'appelle je perds le
père bruno valentin qui est dénommée
ordine ordonné ordonné à ses
d'ordination et ordonné un sel c'est un
peu compliqué en français
teddy solvay et là il a été nommé évêque
auxiliaire de versailles il s'appelle
aux bonnes volontés il est d'ailleurs
évêque auxiliaire d'un débat qui
s'appelle mon cd rom monnier bien nommée
wii
alors on va regarder vous à la halle à
la manifestation de son ordination
et puis je veux raconter après les les
valeurs et les les commentaires qu'ils
aient eu après ce reportage
c'est un véritable bain de foule qui
attendait bruno valentin plus de 2500
personnes ont assisté à son ordination
la cathédrale saint-louis de versailles
quelques jours avant de fêter son 47e
anniversaire l'ancien curé de montigny
voisins le bretonneux devient
officiellement évêque auxiliaire de
versailles
c'est un grand moment de joie cet après
midi pour les catholiques d évident mais
pas seulement il y avait aussi des
représentants des musulmans des juifs
avec des élus qui étaient là et on a
vraiment partagé la même joie c'était un
moment d' enthousiasme et c'est ça
d'abord le souvenir que j'en garderai
dans un contexte sensible pour l'église
catholique bruno valentin aura la charge
d'épauler l'évêque de versailles
monseigneur aumônier dans
l'administration du diocèse
un territoire qui s'étend sur l'ensemble
des yvelines il est le seul à occuper
cette fonction d'évêque auxiliaire en
ile de france
il ya beaucoup à faire
je vais continuer avec lui et avec plus
de d'enthousiasmant encore et comme si
j'avais plus d'énergie dans le public
des curés et fidèle que bruno valentin a
côtoyé lors de ses passages à trappes
château ou encore montini voisin chinois
pour le diocèse
c'est vraiment ça va être un nouvel élan
pour diocèse et c'est une joie qu'on
partage avec tous seraient c'est une
très belle cérémonie très priante est
vraiment entouré de tous les prêtres du
diocèse c'est une cérémonie super mais
là on a vraiment on est heureux d'être
chrétien la communauté chrétienne de
trappes était très représentée
aujourd'hui pendant cette messe
d'ordination voilà on n'a pas oublié il
sera resté à l'écouté de chacun est très
simple dans ces rapports monseigneur
bruno valentin va rencontrer
prochainement la personne à l'origine de
sa nomination le pape françois à rome
voilà donc mon seigneur bruno valentin
nommé évêque oxydé alors ça provoquait
des tas de réaction à l'arrière n'y ait
des réactions notamment qui ont critiqué
cette je cite un cette cérémonie qui
piétine la laïcité
il aurait et musulmans ou juifs le
scandale aurait été grand il est temps
de remettre l'église
à sa place c'est à dire en dehors de la
république et donc c'est une des
réactions vous les voyez là il y en a
une ou deux qui répond bien pas du tout
il est temps de réaffirmer que la france
a des racines chrétiennes et c'est très
bien ben voilà qu'il est servi comme ça
et que ces services soient publiques
ça vous est ce étonnant pas ce genre de
réaction barbus et c'est curieux face et
c'est trés gilet jaune save que des
départs assez curieux ce qu'elle importe
la république verser dans une cathédrale
ce commentaire est juste débile fait
pourquoi le pape de la république
on comprend même pas cesser enfin montre
quand même je ne comprends pas quel
rapport avec la république par rapport
aux commentaires
un commentaire résultat c'est que ça
suscite
voilà un débat encore là aussi qui est
pas très modérée une crispation autour
du phénomène religieux depuis allé ces
dix dernières années si on est généreux
5 en particulier même avec oui une bonne
dizaine avec la jurisprudence on
pratique nous on se rend compte qu'il ya
de plus en plus de contentieux sûr on a
eu des crèches dans les mairies
le burkini la statue du pape jean paul 2
il ya eu un contentieux de masse il ya
beaucoup de questionnements sur la place
que doit avant la manifestation des
religions un pas uniquement de la
religion catholique dans la république
justement donc ce commentaire commente
également quand par exemple la maire de
paris anne hidalgo ne souhaite jamais
joyeux noël mais souhaite toujours un
joyeux ramadan fait une fête pour le
ramadan reçoit les musulmans et c'est
très bien juste assez pour la mairie de
paris met en fête noël on ne fait jamais
donc il n'y a jamais un mot la mairie de
paris pour les jeux joyeux noël en
revanche on fait le ramadan
pourquoi elle vante de parole de la
personne qui donc
mais c'est vrai que c'est dur et ses
passions non mais laissez moi je encore
une fois c'est on parle de crispation
sur un commentaire donc il ya eu
quelques commentaires ils savent qu'on
est un exemple c'était étonnant sur le
sujet comme ça qui aurait pu passer quoi
d'autre elle qui raconte juste voilà
l'ordination d'un évêque et c'est un
petit événement quand même du procureur
on en a quelques-unes elles sont plus
nombreuses que ça je continue c'est que
on a parlé de facebook
à l'heure de la communautarisation c'est
vrai que ce n'est jamais qu'un outil il
se trouve que c'est tout il sait tout
titre part dans cet outil là n'existait
pas il ya quelques années
c'est juste que dans les foyers les gens
parlaient déjà comme ça donc aujourd'hui
ça s'affiche sur des écrans s'affiche
partout on a moyen de polémiquer 516
pour ça que je disais tout à l'heure on
a besoin de connaître la pensée des uns
et des autres c'est cette fameuse
transparente et le fait d'avoir ça sur
nos écrans et pouvoir le lire on a
l'impression qu'ils aient une crispation
banon c'est des gens qui pensent comme
grèce qu'on a toujours pensé comme ça et
moi ça me choque
avant c'était des propos de bistrot ça
restait au niveau du comptoir
maintenant de là à dire qu'il ya une
crispation c'est comme si c'était
nouveau et du coup on rentre dans
quelque chose qui est plus anxiogène
puisque on cristallise sur des propos
comme ça en fait sont faits plus pour
fait les propos toujours existé donc il
ya des gens qui considèrent que la
laïcité doit prendre encore plus de
place il ya des gens qui pensent que la
religion contraire doivent pas en
prendre autant voilà ce débat ce débat
il est malheureusement pas tranchée mais
voilà moi je suis pas choqué par ce que
je viens de voir ça s'est passé à
l'intérieur d'une église
il ya eu il ya eu il ya une cérémonie
comme il peut dire comme le droit
d'ordonner dans l'étang de la franc
maçonnerie
j'ai un moment donné il ya des rituels
qui ce qui se pratique dans la franc
maçonnerie dans les religieux dans les
facultés
quand on ordonne éventuellement 1 il ya
donc il ya donc des rites code mais
voilà il n'ya pas un garçon ne fut ce
qu'est un moment donné c'est quand ça
empiète oui effectivement si la laïcité
c'est un vrai faux malade et c'est vrai
que la crispation sur les religions au
hall on la vit aussi dans les
entreprises
il ya aussi non dans le prime est pas
tant que ça à dire que mais c'est un peu
la même chose que ça et de tout ce que
l'on parle du dos tout ce dont on parle
mais où ne parlera que de lui problème
tu es tu arrivé donc j'ai une autre bris
mois au niveau des entreprises que je
gère et je devrais avoir c'est pas moi
je vais gérer une sorte 50 entreprises
différentes
je n'y a aucune difficulté sur le sujet
il n'y a pas de problème oui il ya eu il
ya des débats mais sur certaines
prophéties sicilien employés qui je lui
touche son hyper clair enfin julien la
jurisprudence allait elle éclaire le
show sont apaisées ne vient pas elle
dira quoi l'édifice jurisprudence nous
dit notamment sur les problématiques du
port du voile parce que ça a été ça la
difficulté
la jurisprudence nous dit qu'on a le
droit dans un règlement intérieur de
préciser qu' il sera interdit
de porter qui assoit le voile ou des
signes extérieurs
dès lors que ça peut soit provoqué un
problème en clientèle dès lors qu'on ma
démarche commerciale et qu'on est en
approche clientèle ou si ça pose des
problèmes en matière d'hygiène et de
sécurité
c'est à dire par exemple pour prendre un
site qui refuse de mettre son casque
parce qu'il a son turban ça pose un
problème d'hygiène et de sécurité sur la
matière de construction sur la photo est
vite mais on va taper ce combat là mais
il ya eu les problèmes qui ont été
peut-être les plus sensibles ce sont des
hommes qui refusent de serrer la main de
femme ça ça a été peut-être les plus
gros problèmes mais finalement ça s'est
toujours sorti par le haut parce qu'il
ya toujours eu des médiations il ya eu
des services rh qui ont été intelligents
décès en date les gens autour de la
table de faire comprendre et c'est plus
de l'éducation des problèmes et ça on
s'en sort quelqu'un qui refuse de serrer
la main d'une femme parce que c'est une
femme
eh ben on est sur des problématiques de
discrimination hommes femmes donc on
s'en sort par ce point là et on est
outillée sur le plan légal et donc là
c'est la même chose on va avoir des gens
peut-être chez pas étaient 200 personnes
qui vont réagir mais bon c'est 100
personnes qui auraient pu autour d'un
comptoir de bar le dire et quand on le
voit on se dit mais c'est ses limites
c'est suis désolé mais ces fachos de
dire des choses comme ça quand je dire
ça montre l'étroitesse d'esprit c'est et
quand je disais tout à l'heure je trouve
que c'est pas c'est du grand n'importe
quoi et c'est pas très démocratique bah
oui c'est pas très démocratique bien ça
prouve une absence d'ouverture d'esprit
sur quelque chose qui est complètement
banale quoi y'a rien de rien
d'extraordinaire
parce que c'est à peu près je rejoins un
peu les deux points de vue c'est à dire
que cette extériorisation d'un discours
qui auparavant se passer dans un cénacle
privé a forcé finalement à une
juridicisation des positions c'est à
dire qu'on a au moins un législateur qui
est intervenu des juges qui ont clarifié
les choses et c'est vrai qu'en droit
public on retrouve à peu près la même
notion d' équilibre c'est à dire le fait
de pouvoir manifester sa religion qui
est une liberté constitutionnelle tout
en respectant la neutralité de l'état
c'est à dire que l'état n'est pas sensé
subventionnés ou et d aucun culte
donc c'est dans cette fameuse position
de posture de neutralité de l'état qu'on
rencontre
mal de problèmes mais bon encore une
fois comme tu le dis la jurisprudence a
là aussi en droit public réussi à
trouver un terrain d'entente notamment
sur les crèches en parlant de la
tradition en essayant de voilà de
retirer certains signes comme la croix
pour pour l'ostentation encore là aussi
une notion assez difficile à définir
mais ce que je crois c'est que comme tu
disais à propos du grand n'importe quoi
c'est que cette cristallisation cette
extériorisation du discours elle a eu
tendance un petit peu à crispées les
positions et que même si en termes
juridiques en termes de droit on a
réussi à trouver des voies d'apaisement
il reste que comme tout le monde se sent
maintenant autorisé un petit peu a donné
son avis sur cette question on a
tendance là encore comme on disait tout
à l'heure à opposer les pros et les
contrats donc ça ça restera un débat a
été intéressant d'avoir l'avis de gens
qui réfléchissent et qu'ils nous
apportent quelque chose moi la vie de
partants piola je vous avais
complètement égal hors jeu juste donner
un exemple peut-être plus parlant que
celui ci dans ma commune
l'église a fermé parce qu'ils avaient
besoin de faire des travaux et le maire
a affecté une salle communale pour que
la messe se tiennent mais je vous dis
pas effectivement
ah oui il ya eu des protestations c'est
une salle communale de la mairie donc ça
doit être laïque et donc il ya aucune
raison de l'affecter à l'église
catholique pour qu'il y ait une messe et
là ça fait énormément de débats dans la
commune est finalement resté mais c'est
plus intéressant mais celle du oui mais
s'est dit justement puisqu'on parle
d'opinion ben c'est ce à quoi tout le
grand débat qui organisées un peu
partout en france qui commence à prendre
forme d'ailleurs c'est intéressant ça
parce que il juste moyen sociologue qui
s'appelle bruno latour qui a fait un
papier dans le monde qui était
intéressant mais disait mais au fond les
opinions des uns et des autres les
nôtres comme ces zones n'ont aucun
intérêt
oui on sait très bien à quoi
vous dire ce grand débat c'est à dire le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne enfin
tous à la proportionnelle on sait à peu
près en ruine quoi ça va aboutir mais il
disait alors il est revenu sur ce qu'est
ce qui s'est passé pendant la révolution
qu'est ce qui est raconté que c'est ce
qui est et ce qu'on avait recensé
c'était pas des opinions c'était la
réalité des situations où vivaient les
gens et 10 s il dit
ce serait plus intéressant au fond
d'avoir une réalité de ce que vivent les
gens et que ce que lui les gens qui sont
à 20 km dans le sud c'est pas forcément
d'une grande ville c'est pas forcément
la même que dans le nord et cdd
il y avait il faudra être très précis et
que ça serait plus intéressant d'avoir
ça que les opinions des uns et des
autres c'est une évidence que l'état des
lieux beaucoup plus intéressant que
connaît les propositions farfelues pour
régler les problèmes que nous avons à
peu près ce que vient de dire si tu es
de l'état de leur situation à l'occasion
des
des grands débats je pense que je pense
que c'est assez intéressant et la
confrontation des manuels macron avec
avec les participants est vraiment été
un phare manche c'est très intéressant
ça participe encore une fois le grand
débat ça participe encore du grand
déballage dont on parlait tout à l'heure
qui satisfait sur les réseaux sociaux
qui se fait partout donc ça fait partie
de cette voie là cette nouvelle
génération on a besoin de s'exprimer
donc qui s'expriment aussi les
concernent
non mais enfin et cela toi qui dis mais
vraiment c'est de l'état des lieux ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'un type
nous raconte sa vie c'est pas qu'ils
nous disent qu'il faudrait baisser la
tva sur les blue jeans sont fous qui ont
hué les dossiers mais il ya une sous la
révolution il
il a regardé c'est contrairement à ce
que tout le monde pense que c'est des
plaintes qui se remonter mais jusqu'à
jusque jusqu'au pouvoir central non
c'était plutôt des descriptions de
situation en tous les cas pour ceux qui
s'expriment c'est par l'état des lieux
parce que ils connaissent leur état des
nues connaissent leur situation ils
l'expriment donc c'est bien de
l'entendre mais c'est des solutions qui
qui demande voir qu'ils proposent
alors c'est pas moi parce qu'ils vont
proposer des solutions mais
effectivement ils n'ont pas toutes les
cartes parce qu'elle menait ses caisses
quel est votre solution c'est la
tradition rigoler ce que j'avais en moi
ce que je pense c'est que ça fait des
progrès ce que les problèmes qu'on a à
résoudre ils sont extrêmement complexes
alors moi je veux bien dire vrai il faut
pas de monter prix de l'essence
c'est pas nouveau l'augmenter mais c'est
pas une solution c'est sait très bien
que les des solutions du monde à venir
ce qu'ils sont extrêmement compliquées
ce qui est intéressant c'est que en
dehors du fait que peut-être chacun va
apporter sa petite solution dont on nous
est égal mais chacun va pouvoir dire
justement sur ce problème de transit
écologique les bretons leur mobilité qui
peuvent ainsi plus intéressants les
sages pour ce que ça va ça va exister
dans les bons temps j'en suis à peu près
sûr je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse un
petit point historique jurant sur ce
qu'étaient les cahiers de doléances suis
pas sûre d'avoir vu comme vous je cours
c'est mon aventure magique
en deux minutes ça ça sera large
simplement rappelé que les cahiers de
doléances étaient aussi rédigé à
l'intention des députés du tiers état en
fait et donc je crois que d'ailleurs
même dans la confrontation entre macro
et les maires de france il ya vraiment
un échelon qu'on oublie qu'ils sont les
députés qui sont normalement censé faire
le lien d'ailleurs avec l'échelon local
et c'est vrai que les cahiers de
doléances de 1789 et même un peu avant
étaient des presque désordre un petit
peu qu'on donnait à son député en disant
voilà dans telle situation j'ai constaté
que et on faisait une forme de j'ai
envie de dire de melting-pot avec tout
ce qu'on avait dans les cagnottes de
l'es11 moore finalement défendre vite la
position du tiers sur une question donc
ici on a des cahiers de doléances qui
sont déconnectés de toute finalité et je
crois que c'est vraiment ça le problème
c'est que on écoute tout le monde sans
savoir vraiment acquise de se réaliser
et pour en faire gloire et c'est
peut-être ça le problème parce qu'au
départ les cahiers de doléances alors tu
dit beaucoup que qu'a priori bon voilà
on écoute un petit peu tout le monde
n'importe comment et que ce mouvement a
pas forcément toujours de sens c'est
possible mais il ya une france qui va
mal c'est ce que notamment les maires de
france ont essayé de faire remonter
auprès d'emmanuel macro et ouvrir ses
cahiers de doléances et aussi entendre
griefs par grief la souffrance de
certains pour essayer d'en faire quelque
chose mais à mon sens pour que ça donne
quelque chose d'aussi utile que les
cahiers de doléances de l'époque il
faudrait qu'on ait un véritable
destinataire de ces cahiers avec une
synthèse alors sûr d'être le
destinataire des gilet jaune sont
spécialement officiel mac c'est d'abord
un comité et ensuite pour former oui
mais c'est pour moi c'est beaucoup de
filtrage quand même ça veut dire qu'il
ya un comité qui va faire des synthèses
des synthèses qui vont être faites par
lorientaise et au final on
et vos projets comme vous l'avez dit
patrice au projet qu'on va retrouver
comme étant le projet de réforme
institutionnelle que vous les manuels
madame non donc quelle finalité va-t-on
donner à tout cela non mais je suis
d'accord avec toi sur sur le process
mais psychologiquement il les gens font
un grand débat pour s'adresser à
emmanuel macron directement puisque le
maire lors alors après parce que le
principe de tout ce gilet jaune c'est il
ya plus de syndicats il ya plus de parti
il ya plus de députés nous c'est la rue
direct au président donc mis en valeur
les entendra bah si pour l'instant parce
qu'ils faisaient la file d'attenté sur
lequel mon idole et les unions et c'est
ça que les gens attendent
mais il est venu jeudi soir était venu
c'est-à-dire impromptue enfin ça n'avait
pas été annoncée dans une réunion en
août au 6 mai après après avoir été les
maires et après je crois que laurent
wauquiez qui l'avait vu jeudi à midi qui
est dit oui enfin voir les maires ça
nous a rien c'est de la population qu'il
faudrait aller voir et n'ira jamais ben
qui est qu'elle soit si facebook est
encore dire joli coup je perds ma
je peux poser une question à mustapha
pourquoi vous savoir poser avec well
pourquoi les ya pas de gilet jaune dans
les banlieues et pourquoi il n'ya
quasiment pas de jeux débats de gilet
jaune dans les débats ou pellets et
pourquoi il n'y a pas non mais pourquoi
n'y a pas de débat dans les débats dans
les banlieues d'ailleurs sur vous sur
les murs sur alger pression mais oui et
pourquoi moi ce qui m'interpelle c'est
qu'il ya pas beaucoup de jeunes d'où
d'où le fait que j'ai appelé moi au gie
les jeunes parce que ça va être
important à un moment donné on parle des
couleurs alors pour le coup toutes les
couleurs parce que sur les terrains de
foot
ils sont tous éligibles et deux couleurs
différentes ça s'appelle tout simplement
des chasubles cette double pendant a
besoin dont l'aspect visage et je pense
je pense qu'il faut qu'on a qu'on a
qu'on a oublié c'est à mon avis cette
jeunesse parce que c'est quand même là
où on doit surtout investir moi
j'entends plein de gens qui se plaignent
de leur situation personnelle je peux
longtemps mais je peux le comprendre
simplement on parle beaucoup faudra
compter sa raison pour laquelle je dis
comptons mais pensons en gilet jaune
imposée
question pourquoi concernés suis pas un
spécialiste de ces questions pour le
coup mais moi ce que je veux ce que je
crois mais mais mais avant de répondre à
ça donc pour moi il ya il ya un péché
originel chez makro on sait que j'ai
pelotant parler de l'ump est 137 dans la
mare parlait souvent
c'était l'idée selon laquelle on pouvait
se regrouper pouvoir travailler au soin
de droite et gauche
il l'a fait mais la conceptualiser et il
l'a fait peser que ce sa personne une
autre personne serait là aujourd'hui
dirait on a laminé les corps
intermédiaires baisse c'est vrai un
moment donné ça tient que sur sa
personne et aujourd'hui c'est lui qu'on
vise mais original mais pour répondre à
ta question florence en tous les cas moi
je vais je vais oser
c'est peut-être que dans les banlieues
finalement on se rend compte que il ya
peut-être un risque finalement à écouter
ce qui se passe c'est que on a le sens
moi quand j'entends on en a pas pour
notre argent
on en a pas on travaille et on en a pas
pour notre argent
ça me laisse à penser que le
consentement à l'impôt le consentement
aux taxes le consentement à au
prélèvement est en train de s'effriter
et si ce consentement seyfried c'est
qu'on est en train de s'effriter aussi
sur d'autres valeurs qui est celle de la
redistribution et en même temps de la
solidarité
donc ça me donne le sentiment que ceux
qui travaillent se disent
j'en ai pas pour mon argent au passage
envie de dire tant mieux parce que si on
en avait pour son argent c'est à dire
qu'on serait pas au chômage
invalide puisque on irait chercher
l'argent que l'on verse pour soi donc si
on a pas pour son avancée par définition
vous n'êtes ni avec ni chômeur ni bref
ni précaire puisque ça va à ces gens là
donc la moitié du salaire va à tous et
de ce que vous pensez à moi c'est que
les banlieues à quel point la solidarité
je me demande à quel point dans les
banlieues il n'y a pas cette idée selon
laquelle sa collection
il ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup à faire
encore il ya beaucoup à progresser mais
ça fonctionne pas trop mal quand même
et quand j'entends ce pays va mal c'est
vrai que quand on se regarde
on se
j'en oublie la formule mairie quand on
se compare et quand on soit en semaine
seule c'est vrai qu'en france on peut
parler dragage des ailes comme je sais
juste que la solution moi je n'ai pas je
sais simplement qu'on y est on ira de
pour avoir d'autres équilibre à des
déséquilibres je pense qu'on est dans
cet état de déséquilibre avant de
trouver d'autres équilibre mais
déquilibre en équilibre on est en train
de de comment dire de d'augmenter à la
fois les solidarités et les
redistributions mais la solution
globalement je ne l'est pas mais ta
question c'est plus à ça que je pense
c'est à dire il y en a qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus conscients que
d'autres parce que peut-être qu'ils les
perçoivent pour les recevoir et d'autres
qui les finance et qui les payent et
donc on arrive ces deux france
maintenant de ceux qui cassent qu'est ce
qui les reçoivent et etc il va peut-être
que c'est un début d'explication mais je
vais y être quand même derrière tout ça
yaya est quand même demande de
renouvellement
donc elles sont sauvées ras de la
démocratie en ça tiens ça non vous avez
un président qui était jupitérien
jusqu'à présent maintenant qu'il est
plus tout qui est au contact avec avec
le peuple qui est presque ne vient
presque un président normal
c'est vrai qu'il ya où il fait des
contradictions dans ce qu'on demande au
président de république mais c'est un
peu ça ce qui se passe non il a essayé d
jupitérien on compte que c'est compliqué
redescend mais moi je pense surtout que
on est en train de réinventer l'eau
chaude et tant mieux parce que si ça
fait bien sûr la seconde mais peut-être
d'un exercice non mais il permet
d'expliquer ce qu'est la démocratie
parce que probablement que peut-être
est-ce que ces jeux démocratie au à
l'ère du numérique c'est quand même une
réflexion importante quoi c'est d'avoir
d'avoir une opinion et de respectueux
celle de l'autre
un moment donné moi j'entends des gens
qui bafoue ça c'est à dire que c'est il
ya une élection on peut en parler
pendant pendant pendant pendant des
heures imaginez qu'ils soient pas
légitime du fait qu'il est il que 25% de
la population comme trump n'a pas eu la
majorité des gens mais des grands
électeurs
on peut en débattre mais à un moment
donné il ya une règle du jeu
elle s'applique à tout le monde le
spectre politique existe en danse et les
ja tous les journaux il y avait il ya
des antiquaires il ya les libéraux on a
toute la panoplie représentative c'est
le veuf qui doit trancher donc si demain
besancenot faisait 56%
j'irai pas moi mettre un gilet rouge
pour dire il n'est pas légitime parce
qu'il est en train de taper le capital
mais il est élu il est élu bât blesse
pendant cinq ans voit ce que ça donne
forcément ça c'est des réseaux savez la
zone et compenser voire la mieux
partagée
une question intéressante dans le dans
les questions institutionnelles qui sont
justement posé dans le grand débat c'est
notamment quelles sont les solutions que
vous préconisez alors si on va avoir
beaucoup d'opinions quelles sont les
solutions vous préconisez pour que le
politique se reconnecte avec la vie
citoyenne et je crois que c'est vraiment
la question qu'est ce qu'on va trouver
il ya le président qui va l'entraîner
maires de france il ya le référendum
sous condition gratteux nous assez
rapide ou peut-être le chiffre de la de
la semaine
ces 14 14% 14% cellule c'est ce que
donne des sondages à une liste jaune des
stooges les jaunes pendant ainsi y avait
listé gilet jaune qui se présentait
évidemment ça fait deux grandes victimes
une grande victime notamment c'est la
liste du rassemblement national
ça fait trois victimes fait souvent ça
fait le
rassemblement national et le choix aussi
du bon aignan et mélenchon veut donc je
pense que la macro ont tous subi
terriens de se frotter les mains d'un
merveilleux qu'il la fasse cette liste
d'où les craies les soupçons que ça soit
des listes est liquidée par après après
politique politiquement et
intellectuellement on peut que ça peut
être c'est une nouvelle assez déprimant
parce qu'on imagine le niveau de 3 g
électorale ces gens là et puis en du
poisson elle va elle va se faire couper
la tête parce qu'il ya déjà les motiver
gilet jaune qui lutte exigent qu'elle
retire son gilet jaune et qu'elle
n'aurait pas le droit de présenter et
messieurs avec le nom gilet jaune donc
attendre philippot a eu l'intelligence
où la finalité malin d'aller déposer les
gilet jaune donc si c'est lui qui
s'estime légitime pour représenter ce
mouvement là aussi la question se posera
en même temps on peut faire comment ce
gilet jaune pour s'asseoir sur toute
légalité pour dire filippo peut toujours
avoir déposé ce qu'il veut quand même
temps que le rat comme on nettoie de la
ville a dit qu'il avait des nausées mais
qui ne le regarderai pas pour lui on
nous devons tirer de plus d'une minute
le débat miniski qui participent ou qui
co animent un débat avec eux si elle
hanouna ça vous attend attendons de voir
c'est un tueur elle de mots on dit
qu'avec les 1 vendredi soir
si ça se trouve elle et falco à nîmes
pas et vient d'inviter cantat pile
faisait personne personne n'a râlé quand
jospin pousser la chansonnette la
personne n'a râlé giscard jouer de
l'accordéon
aussi convient il savait tout
l'eure-et-loir et arrêtons et arrêtez de
mépriser hanouna moi c'est pas du tout
ma tête le sujet le sujet n'est pas le
sujet c'est que quand on est minime
est ce qu'un ministre co animer une
émission qui soit invité les problèmes
secondes
est-ce que vous en fais ce que vous
soyez énervé comme ça si marlène
schiappa avait dit je vais co animer la
grande librairie avec françois busnel
franchement tout le monde à aller c'est
merveilleux la culture en diable le
problème étant de l'aborder et c est en
voie là c'est les manuels macro qui
prend la parole c'est c'est bien le sien
pas est ce que c'est la parole des gens
qui sont au pouvoir qu'on attend parce
que c'est la parole des gens ils sont en
bas justement la france d'en bas qu'on
attend c'est ce jour il retourne un
exercice qu'ils savent faire parce que
en marche précisément ce qu'ils ont fait
pendant la campagne qui reprennent la
main c'est fini merci merci infiniment à
tous les quatre et et puis à très vite
pour un nouveau prof
[Musique]